la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu l'observation il y
en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas il est donc adopté sous
les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en
direction Public Sénat et sur notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au respect
des uns et des autres et à celui du
temps de parole je donne immédiatement
la parole aux présidents Jean-Claude
Roquier pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre après la crise des
gilets jaunes et la pandémie de covid-19
qui a mis à l'arrêt le monde durant deux
années notre pays est confronté depuis
plusieurs mois un nouveau choc
économique majeur avec l'explosion des
coûts de l'énergie et puis largement de
très fortes de prix des matières
premières et de l'alimentation cette
accélération de l'inflation en partie
importée frappe désormais toute notre
économie et le quotidienne nos
compatriotes engendrant de fortes
tensions sociales dans de nombreux
secteurs les revendications de
revalorisation salariale sont bien sûr
légitimes dans un contexte
inflationniste auquel nous étions plus
habitués nous devons entendre ce qui
demande une répartition plus juste de la
valeur ajoutée à laquelle il contribue
et une rémunération digne leur travail
la solidarité doit aussi continuer à
s'exercer envers les plus fragiles
dans ce climat social tendu le dialogue
il a négociation doivent demeurer les
outils de la sortie de crise en
particulier dans les raffineries et où
les transports publics les rois
négations sont connues et ont pu
s'exprimer elles ne peuvent cependant
plus justifiées un blocage indéfini
notre économie oui de pénaliser des
millions de personnes et d'entraîner le
pays dans une boucle de récession nous
sommes dans la première ministre la
volonté de notre gouvernement a œuvré
pour le pouvoir d'achat et le niveau de
vie des Français nous nous comptons
aussi sur la responsabilité des
entreprises pour répondre selon long
terme aux attentes des salariés madame
ministre comment comptez-vous maintenant
agir pour répondre aux attentes de nos
combattants
pour vous répondre la parole du keV Adam
la première ministre
monsieur le
président dans un département où la
voiture n'est pas un luxe c'est une
nécessité pour le travail pour le
quotidien et je sais votre attention
votre attention particulière à tous nos
compatriotes qui veulent vivre de leur
travail qui s'inquiète face à la montée
des prix qui subissent de plein fouet
les tensions d'approvisionnement dans
les stations services et craignent le
blocage du pays monsieur le Président
Roquier c'est préoccupations ce sont
aussi les nôtres certains cultivent les
inquiétudes et veulent les changer en
colère nous tout comme vous monsieur le
Président nous voulons y répondre
apaiser le pays et rassembler les
Français
aussi pour protéger nos compatriotes
face à l'inflation nous avons pris dès
le précédent quinquennat des mesures
fortes avec un bouclier tarifaire dès
octobre 2021
en juillet vous avez voté des textes
d'urgence en faveur du pouvoir d'achat
et plus récemment j'ai annoncé la
prolongation des boucliers tarifaires et
le maintien jusqu'à mi-novembre de la
remise de 30 centimes sur les carburants
ce sont les mesures les plus
protectrices d'Europe et nous avons
l'inflation la plus basse de la zone
euro
mais je car je garde une conviction une
conviction que nous avons en commun sur
bon nombre de ces rangs une conviction
partagée par nos compatriotes le pouvoir
d'achat durable viendra du travail alors
concernant particulièrement les salaires
vous le savez notre pays dispose d'un
système unique au monde de
revalorisation automatique du SMIC de ce
fait le SMIC a augmenté de 8% en un an
c'est-à-dire plus que l'inflation qui
est autour de 6%
cette augmentation doit conduire en
conséquence à une revalorisation des
grilles salariales dans les différentes
branches professionnelles la dynamique
est lancée puisque depuis le début de
l'année plus de 500 accords de branches
sur les salaires ont été signés
mais au-delà je l'ai dit je le crois et
je le répète les entreprises qui le
peuvent doivent augmenter les salaires
elle le doivent d'autant plus dans le
contexte d'inflation et elles ont une
responsabilité particulière si elles ont
réalisé plus de profits malgré le
contexte
pour y parvenir des négociations doivent
se tenir dans les branches et dans les
entreprises et elles doivent avoir lieu
rapidement car j'en suis convaincu la
solution vient toujours du dialogue
social le blocage le refus de la
discussion par une minorité ou la grève
préventive ne sont jamais les solutions
et je pense ici à tous les Français qui
rencontrent encore aujourd'hui des
difficultés pour trouver du carburant
heureusement la situation s'améliore
mais nous serons mobilisés jusqu'à un
retour à la normale je vous remercie
monsieur le président
la France rurale et la France
périphérique sans transport collectif
suffisant ont besoin de se déplacer de
voiture et les voitures sauf les
électriques ont besoin d'essence il faut
approvisionner les stations services
dans cette France là la voiture était
dispensable et contrairement au
centre-ville qui la bannissent son
usage est apprécié et le terme bagnoles
n'y est pas un gros mot merci monsieur
le président
[Applaudissements]
j'ai donné la parole à notre collègue
Daniel Breuillet pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire
qui est le président madame la Première
ministre ma question est simple
travaillons-nous pour rien
Conseil national de la refondation
travail transpartisan dialogue de Bercy
votre gouvernement démultiplie les
annonces et les rendez-vous dit le
concertation mais en même temps vous
laissez planer depuis plusieurs mois la
menace du recours éventuel potentielle à
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution et
cela sur les sujets essentiels de la vie
des Françaises et des Français les
retraites l'assurance chômage le projet
de loi de finance cette conception de la
démocratie est déroutante surtout dans
ce contexte de crise multiple et
d'inquiétude grandissante des citoyens
comme des collectivités les
mobilisations contre la vie chère
l'inaction climatique ou pour la hausse
des salaires montre bien les attentes de
nombre de nos compatriotes les députés
ont en responsabilité face aux besoins
de justice sociale et écologique
largement amender le projet de loi de
finance c'est le rôle des consensus ont
été trouvés par exemple pour que ma
prime rénove finance davantage des
rénovations globales que des petits
travaux ou encore pour taxer à 35% des
super dividendes je pense également au
crédit d'impôt pour le reste à charge de
tous les résidents en EHPAD madame la
Première ministre alors que vous
choisissez décourter les débats au moyen
du 49-3 prenez vous l'engagement de
présenter au Sénat le projet de loi de
finances enrichi par le travail
parlementaire de nos collègues députés
pouvez-vous nous assurer que nous ne
travaillons pas pour rien et nous
confirmer que nos amendements
sénatoriaux n'ont pas également vocation
à disparaître dans les poubelles de tri
présidentielle ou bien nous préciser le
cas échéant s'il faut désormais
soumettre nos amendements directement au
président de la République
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Daniel Bruyer merci
pour votre question merci d'abord
d'avoir souligné en préambule la
démarche qui est celle du gouvernement
depuis des mois désormais celle de la
concertation de la main tendue de la
volonté farouche de travailler en commun
et d'arriver à trouver au-delà des
clivages politiques traditionnels
des voix des chemins de crêtes pour
pouvoir travailler ensemble au un
intérêt général pour notre pays il en
est ainsi avec l'examen du budget vous
l'avez souligné c'est le huitième jour
du débat à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
partie 1 du projet de loi de finance les
débats sont riches ils sont passionnants
passionnés évidemment certains consensus
ont pu être trouvés et le gouvernement
par la voie de la première ministre a
déjà annoncé que quelle qu'en soit
l'issue il s'engageait à reprendre un
certain nombre d'amendements qui avait
permis d'enrichir le texte venant des
majorités et des rangs des oppositions
madame la sénatrice vous dites tous si
je devais faire le compte à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle nous en sommes à
8 milliards de sur dépenses il nous
devions tenir compte de la totalité des
amendements des oppositions tels
qu'adopter en première lecture 8
milliards qui ne sont pas financés 8
milliards qui correspondraient ou à de
la dette supplémentaire pour notre pays
ou à des impôts supplémentaires pour les
Français or
si le chemin du dialogue est réel et si
la volonté de trouver des compromis je
le redis et permanente nous ne rognerons
pas sur un certain nombre de principes
qui sont chers au président de la
République à la première ministre et à
cette majorité il n'y aura pas de hausse
d'impôts il n'y aura pas de hausse de la
dette nous ne détricoterons pas
l'ensemble des mécanismes qui ont permis
à notre pays de retrouver son
attractivité et sa richesse en 5 ans et
nous ne régnerons pas nous ne renierons
pas les engagements qui ont été pris par
le Président de la République lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle et pour
lesquelles il a été élu je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre retenez nos
propositions comme les taxations des
super profits la démocratie sans
dialogue social et sans Parlement ce
n'est plus tout à fait la démocratie
la parole est maintenant
au président Claude Malhuret pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoires monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre les idées
des cégeistes si j'ose accolé ces deux
mots sont simples
total ne nous accorde que 8%,
vengeons-nous sur les Français ouvriers
bloqué dans les queues des stations
services infirmières en panne et leur
patients qui attendront artisans ou
chantier suspendus le syndicalisme trash
c'est ça des salariés payés le double de
la moyenne qui empêche les autres de
travailler et qui en plus prétendent les
défendre à tous ceux tenter de croire à
cette arnaque à tous ceux tenter de
croire à cette arnaque je voudrais
rappeler ce dicton on finit toujours par
payer le joueur de pipeau le comble du
cynisme c'est quand on apprend que ces
grèves n'ont rien à voir avec le pouvoir
d'achat mais que c'est réglement de
compte à CGT chorale les dures de la Fée
des chimie mécontent que Martinez fidèle
à sa conception de la démocratie est
nommée tout seul sa successeur qu'il
trouve trop molle déclenche la grève
pour le déstabiliser
pour les faire taire il en rajoute dans
la radicalité sur le dos des Français
comme toujours personne n'est dupe et
l'automne show que nous promettent les
agents d'ambiance de l'agit propre
piétine les grèves sont condamnées par
une majorité de Français la journée
d'hier fut un échec comme le fut
dimanche la marche des Grosso marxistes
de la nuque emmenés par le Che Guevara
de nations
la prochaine étape la prochaine étape
est encore plus obscène la récession
guette la planète le prix de l'énergie
met des usines à l'arrêt les Français
vont avoir froid cet hiver mais la même
CGT pour la plus grande joie de Poutine
empêche la maintenance des centrales
nucléaires qui nous permettraient de
surmonter l'arrêt du gaz russe madame la
Première ministre vous avez commencé de
prendre les réquisitions qui s'imposent
pouvez-vous nous assurer que vous
poursuivrez toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour que 90% de 90 personnes
pardon ne puisse interdire à la moitié
de la France de se déplacer et que
quelques centaines d'autres ne puissent
empêcher nos concitoyens de se chauffer
au cœur de l'hiver
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Malhuret
le conflit social chez Total et so a des
répercussions dans tout notre pays et
touche le quotidien de millions de
Français
comme vous monsieur le Président malgré
j'entends et je partage et
préoccupations de nos concitoyens qui
craignent de ne pas avoir de carburant
pour aller travailler que leur aide à
domicile ne puisse pas passer qui crée
une de devoirs renoncer à retrouver
leurs proches pendant les vacances de la
Toussaint
pour eux nous devions agir fort et vite
en lien avec le président de la
République le Gouvernement est
totalement mobilisé et je réunis
quotidiennement une cellule
interministérielle de crise pour
coordonner l'action des services de
l'État
dès les premiers jours de la grève nous
avons pris des mesures pour augmenter
les livraisons de carburant dans les
stations services nous avons notamment
libéré des stocks stratégiques de l'État
nous avons augmenté les importations
nous avons autorisé l'ouverture des
dépôts et les livraisons le week-end ces
mesures ont eu des effets importants sur
les livraisons de carburant et ces
derniers jours elles étaient jusqu'à
deux fois plus importante qu'en temps
normal mais les inquiétudes des Français
contenus des inquiétudes des Français
face aux risques de pénurie nous avons
assisté à une augmentation de la demande
plus forte que cette augmentation des
livraisons aussi il était essentiel de
sortir du conflit social je me suis
impliqué personnellement pour que le
dial social et lieu chez So et chez
Total et dans ces deux entreprises des
accords ont pu être signés avec des
syndicats représentant une majorité des
salariés quand il y a un accord
majoritaire le travail doit reprendre
une minorité ne peut pas ne doit pas
bloquer le pays c'est la raison pour
laquelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé au préfet de réquisitionner les
personnels nécessaires au fonctionnement
dans certains dépôts aujourd'hui avec la
fin du conflit social chez Esso et
l'ensemble des mesures prises par le
gouvernement la situation continue à
s'améliorer nettement au plan national
ce matin 20% des stations étaient en
rupture sur au moins un produit elles
étaient 30% ce week-end et peut-être
plus précisément parce que la situation
peut être contrastée par territoire je
voudrais souligner que la situation
s'améliore sur tout le territoire dans
les hauts de France on était à 55% de
stations en rupture il y a une semaine
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 15%. en
Île-de-France avec le débloqué pardon la
situation se s'améliore également avec 8
8 points de moins sur le nombre de
stations bloquées et dans votre région
en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes le déblocage du
dépôt de Feyzin permet des améliorations
sensibles depuis hier matin nous sommes
passés de 36% à 26% de stations en
rupture je sais que la situation est
encore difficile pour beaucoup de nos
combattriotes mais la dynamique est là
et je veux une nouvelle fois appelée les
salariés grévistes à reprendre le
travail il est inacceptable qu'une
minorité bloque un pays et de notre côté
monsieur le Président nous continuerons
à agir jusqu'au retour à la normale je
vous remercie
la parole est maintenant au président
Bruno Retailleau pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre depuis dimanche dernier la
France est sous le choc
Lola une jeune fille de 12 ans
a été sauvagement agressé et les mortes
agressée par une ressortissante
algérienne qui n'aurait pas dû être sur
le sol français
depuis dimanche des voies célèvent pour
que d'autres devoirs se taisent pour
imposer le silence
pour bâillonner le débat
mais l'essence même de la démocratie mes
chers collègues précisément cette
questionnement c'est le débat le meurtre
de Lola me rappelle un autre meurtre qui
m'avait touché personnellement
le meurtrier à l'époque était depuis
plus de 10 ans situation irrégulière il
était sur le sol de France
il avait été frappé par trois occultuf
il n'était pas expulsé il a incendié la
cathédrale de Nantes il n'était pas en
prison
il avait une santé précaire mentale il
n'était pas un hôpital psychiatrique et
vous voudriez madame le Premier ministre
que nous nous taisions ce sont les
Français qui réclament des comptes et il
faut l'admettre le désordre migratoire
peut tuer si cette algérienne n'avait
pas été sur le sol français Lola aurait
été encore en vie j'ai une double
question à vous poser la première
reconnaissez-vous des défaillances de
l'État
une part de responsabilité
la seconde que dites-vous aux Français
pour que ces tragédies et ces drames ne
se reproduisent plus
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la première minute
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
mess
ieurs le taillot
je crois qu'on politique quel que soit
les circonstances nous devons toujours
faire le choix de la dignité
[Applaudissements]
une jeune fille une jeune fille de 12
ans une jeune fille de 12 ans a été tuée
dans des conditions effroyables une
famille des amis des voisins un collège
sont en deuil et tout le pays partagent
leur émotion
c'est pour les parents de Lola que je
veux avoir mes premiers mots le
président de la République a eu
l'occasion de les recevoir hier et de
leur dire toutes les motion et la
solidarité de la nation et je souhaite à
nouveau dire à cette famille
au nom du gouvernement et j'en suis sûr
en votre nom à tous notre plein de
soutien
et monsieur le Président Retailleau
savez-vous ce qu'on demandait les
parents de Lola
du respect la paix pour la mémoire de
Lola et qu'on les laisse faire leur
deuil dans la dignité
nous le leur devons et je le dis
franchement je crois que la dignité nous
commande de ne pas exploiter la douleur
indicible d'une famille de ne pas
utiliser la mort d'une enfant à des fins
politiciennes
[Applaudissements]
ce que nous devons à la mémoire de Lola
et à toute sa famille c'est la justice
une enquête a été immédiatement lancée
les services de police ont pu identifier
et interpellé des suspects en quelques
heures deux personnes ont été mises en
examen par les juges d'instruction et
l'une d'elles se trouve en détention
provisoire
l'enquête se poursuit aujourd'hui pour
déterminer précisément les faits
et il y a une autre chose à laquelle je
crois profondément monsieur le Président
c'est à l'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire je ne veux donc pas d'autre
commentaires à faire laissons les
enquêteurs travailler
laissons la famille de Lola faire son
deuil en paix nous leur devons justice
ils l'auront et c'est la République qui
la rendra je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre vous vous
trompez en réduisant la mort de Lola un
simple fait divers je pense vous voyez
que la politique se diminue quand elle
refuse le débat je pense que la
politique ne peut pas se contenter de
pleurer sur les conséquences elle doit
en dénoncer aussi clairement les causes
elle doit affronter la réalité pour que
ces meurtres ne se reproduisent plus
madame la Première ministre que vous
êtes une responsable public chaque
responsable public doit avoir le courage
d'affronter la réalité et doit protéger
les Français avec une politique inse
abandonne pas justement au laxiste et au
laisser faire migratoires vous devez
prendre des décisions tout de suite pour
aujourd'hui pour demain
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Loïc
Hervé pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances et la souveraineté industrielle
numérique ou plutôt à Monsieur le
Ministre délégué en charge de
l'Industrie
le Mondial de l'auto a été l'occasion
d'annonce politique d'importance pour
continuer d'accompagner la filière vers
sa transformation qu'il s'agisse d'un
entretien du président de la République
dans Les Echos ou des propres
déclarations du ministre Bruno Le Maire
toute la filière automobile française
des noms d'ordre au sous-traitants est
un Fleurot qu'il nous faut savoir
préserver malgré les contraintes
considérables auxquelles l'ensemble de
cette filière se trouve confronté qu'ils
agissent du coût de l'énergie de la
compétitivité ou des normes le virage de
l'électricité va nécessiter en soi des
évolutions majeures de l'outil de
production après les différentes vagues
du plan de relance de nouvelles aides
sont prévues
dans mon département de la Haute-Savoie
singulièrement dans la vallée de larve
l'industrie du décolletage est au cœur
de ses enjeux et avec quelques ETI mais
surtout une myriade de PME qu'il faut
accompagner une par une avec les
meilleures chances d'être aidé
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
garantir que les aides pourront bien
aller aux autres prises qui le méritent
comment envisagez-vous de garantir
l'accès équitable à ses aides pour
toutes les entreprises sans qu'elle
n'ait l'obligation implicite d'avoir
recours à des cabinets chasseurs de
primes dont les rémunérations sont
indécentes et qui a moins de risques
d'autant le volume des aides versées je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole de tobinus
délégués chargés de l'industrie monsieur
Lescure
sur le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Loïc
Hervé cette question est vue vous l'avez
dit tombe bien puisque nous sommes la
semaine du Mondial de l'Automobile le
premier et le sol salon en Europe cette
année le premier depuis 4 ans auquel est
adjoint également le salon EquipAuto
donc on a toute la filière les
constructeurs et les équipements entiers
réunis à la Porte de Versailles sur vos
moments perdus je vous engage à y aller
parce que c'est toute l'industrie
automobile française qui brille vous
l'avez dit le gouvernement a accompagné
cette filière dans un moment difficile
la covid France relance pour l'industrie
automobile c'est environ 750 millions et
pour votre département que nous avons
visité avec Bruno Le Maire il y a
quelques semaines la filière de la
vallée de l'arbre vous y était là la
filière du décolletage a été le premier
département accompagné avec 54 millions
d'euros d'argent public qui ont conduit
à 125 au total millions d'euros
d'investissement pour accompagner la
filière on va continuer on va même
accélérer j'irai plus loin que ce que
vous disiez vous disiez l'objectif elle
est de préserver la filière non
l'objectif il est de la développer de
s'assurer que l'industrie automobile qui
va prendre le virage de
l'électrification le face en toute
souveraineté en réindustrialisant nos
territoires et en développant ses
filières qui en ont bien besoin vous
l'avez dit pour cela il faut annoncer il
faut accompagner toute la filière y
compris les petits sous-traitants
qualificatifs que j'apprécie pas
beaucoup parce qu'ils sont petits par la
taille mais extrêmement important dans
la filière et notamment chez vous en
s'assurant que les 5 milliards d'euros
dont un milliard d'euros dédié à la
sous-traitance qui sont au sein de
France 2030 destinés à accompagner la
filière puisse aussi toucher les petits
et moyennes entreprises
je ne suis évidemment pas là pour
choisir à la place des empreintes
entrepreneurs quel cabinet de conseils
ils vont choisir ou pas pour demander
tel ou telle aide mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que nous souhaitons que
les appels d'offres soient simples que
les appels soient accessibles et qu'on
puisse même sur le terrain organisé un
accompagnement public des entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent remplir ses
appels d'offres on s'appuiera notamment
sur les chambres de commerce et sur les
pôles de compétitivité pour que les
entreprises pardon petite moyenne ou
grande puissent profiter à plein de
France 2030 merci
Monsieur Hervé merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur Miss pour vous
répondre ça tombe mal le pôle de
compétitivité de la vallée de larve il a
été assassiné politiquement il y a
quelques mois donc il n'existe plus donc
pour ce qui est chambre de commerce il
reste et Chambre de Commerce vous avez
raison mais la structuration collective
de dans la dans la vallée de l'arbre et
en Haute-Savoie ça reste quelque chose
de très important apprenons de ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières années avec
les trois vagues du plan de relance et
moralisons l'octroi des aides pour que
toutes les entreprises et la capacité
d'avoir des aides merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Noëlle Linde pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste ils avaient la parole
monsieur le ministre de l'Industrie
en quelques semaines deux fleurons de
notre industrie aéronautique et spatial
passe ou pavillon américain
et deviennent propriétés de la même
société Aiko
la société excelia qui intervient dans
l'aéronautique le spatial l'armement
mais aussi dans le médical qui plus est
cette société devrait bénéficier du
programme France 2030 la société trad
spécialisée dans la technologie des
tests et analyse des effets de radiation
sur les matériaux et composants
électroniques fondamental pour la
recherche spatiale les avions de haute
altitude et l'armement entre autres
comment ne pas voir qu'il s'agit là de
secteur de haute technologie
essentiel pour l'autonomie stratégique
de la France et qui concourt à notre
souveraineté industrielle comment
pouvez-vous laisser faire ça
doit-on revoir le sinistre scénario
consécutif aux décisions d'Emmanuel
Macron avec la vente des turbines
arabels essentielle pour les centrales
nucléaires à l'Américain général
électrique pour devoir aujourd'hui les
racheter ou double du prix de vente sans
récupérer les licences pertes d'emploi
d'argent de savoir-faire vous auriez dû
vous en souvenir alors Monsieur le
Ministre pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
déclenché le décret Montebourg qui
permet au gouvernement de contrôler les
investissements étrangers en France dans
les secteurs clés que comptez-vous faire
pour qu'exelia et trad reste française
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste déléguée chargée de
l'industrie monsieur Lescure
mesdames Messieurs les signataires
madame la sénatrice linman d'abord
peut-être rappeler
le ce que vous appelez le décrément de
bourre qui est en fait la procédure
investissement est trajet en France qui
a été à la fois élargiée renforcé dans
le monde après ses dents en accord
d'ailleurs entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
j'étais à l'époque président de la
Commission de l'affaire économique et
rapporteur général de la wapaq et
beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet nous
avons élargi les secteurs concernés nous
avons aussi renforcé la procédure de
contrôle du Parlement sur ces
investissements étrangers en France une
fois par an vous avez un rapport qui
vous êtes envoyé qui vous permet d'avoir
la liste des vis le nombre
d'investissements concernés et ceux qui
ont fait l'objet d'autorisation sous
conditions je vous rappelle qu'en 2021
dossiers ont été soumis à la procédure
dite Montebourg investissement étranger
en France et sur ces 328 124 124 pardon
est autorisé dont 67 sous conditions
allez plus loin suppose de mettre en
cause le secret des affaires et parfois
le secret de la défense nationale et
c'est pour pallier ce défaut que dans le
cadre encore de la loi pacte nous avons
voté une disposition particulière qui
fait que sur des cas particuliers les
présidents des commissions des affaires
économiques du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
les rapporteurs généraux du budget
peuvent sur le coup du sucré du secret
pardon examiner des cas particuliers
mais vous comprendrez bien que pour les
deux raisons susmentionnées je ne peux
commenter en détail des cas particuliers
comme ceux que vous mentionnez sachez
pour autant que ce soit pour la société
trad et pour la société excellia vous
mentionnez évidemment nous avons à cœur
les intérêts stratégiques de la nation
la souveraineté industrielle
industrielle et les enjeux de ces crédit
en France quand nous ex ces dossiers et
nous l'avons fait et nous continuons à
le faire merci Madame
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Michel Dagbert pour le grand du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier
dusoft ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion monsieur le
ministre si depuis 2004 les départements
assurent avec le concours de l'État le
versement de l'allocation au profit des
bénéficiaires du RSA l'exercice de cette
compétence a été et demeure au cœur de
bien des discussions entre département
et gouvernement successifs les
départements sont aussi en charge de
l'accompagnement social et ou
professionnels de chaque bénéficiaire
cette politique publique participe et
c'est heureux à la cohésion sociale du
pays sans remettre en cause la
détermination des élus départementaux le
professionnalisme de leurs équipes et
tout en leur reconnaissant un certain
nombre de réussites il est à noter que
malgré la baisse significative du
chômage une longue liste de propositions
d'emplois restent non pourvu
les secteurs concernés sont diverses
serveurs de café restaurant agent
d'entretien ATSEM aide à domicile à
déménagère voire même professionnel de
l'animation socioculturelle de quoi
réinterroger légitimement la déquation
entre les parcours d'insertion proposés
et la réalité du marché de l'emploi je
sais Monsieur le Ministre que quelques
départements se sont portés volontaires
pour une expérimentation celle-ci fait
craindre à une importante association du
secteur social une réforme qui selon
elle s'apparente à un retour du servage
n'ayant aucun doute sur la volonté qui
vous anime en la matière pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre devant mes
collègues de la Chambre haute préciser
les contours de cette évolution des
politiques d'insertion et nous en donner
le calendrier
pour vous répondre la parole du comédie
du travail plein emploi de l'insertion
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Dagbert vous l'avez dit pendant
la campagne des élections
présidentielles le président de la
République alors candidat a réinterrogé
les modalités et la réussite du modèle
et du l'outil qui est le RSA RSA
héritier du RMX en 1988 avec cette
volonté et c'est une fierté notre modèle
social d'accorder et d'apporter un
concours minimum un revenu minimum
celles et ceux qui se retrouvent sans
revenu aujourd'hui les résultats en
matière d'insertion d'intégration
professionnelle de retour à l'emploi ne
sont pas des résultats satisfaisants ils
ne sont pas satisfaisants parce qu'un
rapport des la Cour des comptes l'a
montré au premier semestre de l'année
2022 7 ans après l'entrée dans le RSA
42% des bénéficiaires sont encore
bénéficiaires du RSA de manière
permanente ou de manière discontinue
mais extrêmement régulière de la même
manière 7 ans après l'entrée dans le RSA
seul trois bénéficiaires sur 10 on
retrouve un emploi et seul un sur 10 à
retrouver un emploi stable ça nous
oblige que ça nous oblige à agir nous
pouvons continuer à croire ou à penser
que la société serait quitte de son
devoir de solidarité une fois qu'elle
aura attribué une indemnité d'un peu
moins de 600 euros à une personne
dépourvue de revenus la conviction du
gouvernement la conviction que défend
devant vous et que la société sera
quitte de son devoir solidarité de ce
que leur a permis le retour à l'emploi
parce que l'emploi le travail et
l'élément d'émancipation d'autonomie de
dignité et la capacité à retrouver un
revenu comment allons-nous le faire nous
allons le faire avec un accompagnement
plus intensif des bénéficiaires du RSA
et je dis tout net devant vous il n'a
jamais été question ni de travail
gratuit ni de bénévolat obligatoire il
s'agit de formation il s'agit
d'accompagnement il s'agit de
remobilisation collective et
individuelles mais il ne s'agit ni de
bénévolat obligatoire ni de travail
gratuit c'est important à souligner
parce que ça ne correspond pas aux
modèles qui est le nôtre le président de
la République l'a dit le RSA est un
droit inconditionnel pour tous ceux qui
sont privés de revenus le devoir de la
puissance publique de toute la puissance
publique et de garantir une offre
d'insertion informations adaptée
personnalisée partout sur le territoire
et de ce que ces deux conditions sont
remplies il y a une logique de droit et
devoirs pour faire en sorte que ceux qui
en bénéficient s'inscrivent dans ces
parcours de retour vers l'emploi et
d'insertion par l'emploi
[Applaudissements]
parce que
la parole maintenant notre collègue
Monique Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre le prix du gasoil
dépasse les 2 euros le litre les tarifs
des différentes sources d'énergie
augmente considérablement les produits
de première nécessité tels que les pâtes
ou le beurre voient leur prix augmenter
de 22 à 47%, la liste est longue de tout
ce qui concourt à la vie quotidienne des
Français dont une partie d'entre eux
n'aura pas d'autres choix que de se
priver dans les semaines à venir et nous
savons tous ici qui seront les premiers
à sacrifier des biens pourtant
indispensables à ce que l'on qualifie de
vie descente vous répondez primes
aléatoire défiscalisation et
désocialisation d'heures supplémentaires
rachat de RTT et autres mesures qui
finalement n'impliquent que les salariés
eux-mêmes mais vous refusez obstinément
de satisfaire notre demande et surtout
celle des salariés d'initier un grand
débat sur les salaires
les salariés ne demandent pas l'aumône
ils veulent vivre de leur travail vous
ne cessez de rappeler la valeur travail
souvent d'ailleurs pour stigmatiser ceux
qui en sont privés nous vous répondons
pas de valeur travail sans travail de
valeur et la valeur d'un travail se
mesure entre autres à l'aune de sa
rémunération depuis 2008 les salaires
des 10% les mieux payés ont augmenté
trois fois plus vite que ceux des 10%
les moins rémunérés est-ce que le
travail du patron d'une grande enseigne
vaut 300 fois le travail de sa caissière
il est temps de parler du partage de la
masse salariale dans les entreprises
quand metrez-vous à l'oeuvre une
conférence nationale afin de poser enfin
tous ces sujets et soutenir par la même
tous les salariés de France
on vous réponde la parole est au
ministre du Travail
Monsieur Olivier du shop merci monsieur
le Président Madame la signatrice Lubin
vous avez débuté votre question par
l'inflation et la situation de
l'inflation et je pense que vous auriez
pu faire le constat avec nous que nous
sommes le pays en Europe qui parlait
mesures mises en place le bouclier
tarifaire sur les questions énergétiques
les aides que nous apportons au ménage a
permis de réduire l'inflation le plus
possible nous sommes autour de 6,5%,
c'est beaucoup c'est plus que ce que
nous avons connu depuis 1985 mais c'est
bien souvent presque la moitié de ce que
connaissent nos voisins européens et
c'est aussi la démonstration que la
politique que nous menons protège les
Français vous nous appelez finalement à
une augmentation de salaire nous avons
une conviction c'est qu'une augmentation
générale de salaire ne se décide pas par
la loi la relève du dialogue social j'y
reviendrai nous avons une autre
conviction c'est que l'augmentation ou
l'indexation du SMIC que vous avez
parfois appelé de vos vœux dans les
débats ne concerne finalement qu'une
partie des salariés alors que notre
position est de nourrir de pousser au
dialogue social la première ministre l'a
dit tout à l'heure nous engageons nous
encourageons les branches et les
entreprises au dialogue et dans le cadre
du dernier projet de loi de financement
rectificatif vous avez voté le Parlement
à voter des mécanismes permettant
d'accélérer l'ouverture des négociations
dès lors que un des niveaux de
rémunération conventionnel serait
inférieur au SMIC il faut ajouter à cela
des outils que vous n'avez pas mentionné
vous avez parlé défiscalisation vous
avez parlé des socialisation vous avez
oublié de dire les efforts que nous
faisons pour améliorer le partage de la
valeur faire en sorte que les accords
d'intéressement soient plus facile faire
en sorte que les primes que vous
qualifiez aléatoires et qui bénéficient
à des millions de Français soit elles
aussi plus facile à verser je peux vous
assurer que celles et ceux qui peuvent
en bénéficier sont heureux d'en
bénéficier bien plus que les mots vous
prononcez pour les décrire ou pour les
qualifier vous avez dit que depuis 2008
d'ailleurs cela interroge sur la
responsabilité des uns et des autres
tout ce confondu de sur cette même
période il y aurait un écart croissant
qui s'est creusé grâce aux outils de
redistribution dans notre pays dispose
l'écart entre le premier et le dernier
des cils ne s'est pas creuser il ne
s'est pas creuser parce que nous avons
un système redistributif qui permet de
compenser les écarts entre les revenus
primaires et nous devons aussi en faire
une fierté dans quelques semaines
j'aurai l'occasion sous l'autorité de la
première ministre d'ouvrir une
négociation interprofessionnelle sur le
partage de la valeur ça sera une
première et j'espère que l'énergie que
vous mettez à critiquer la politique du
gouvernement vous pourrez l'utiliser un
meilleur escient on accompagnant cette
discussion
mon énergie monsieur le ministre je
continuerai à la déployer au service des
salariés qui malgré tout ce que vous
venez de nous dire et donc une partie
effectivement relève du factuel
notamment sur les aides mais tout ce que
vous venez de nous dire visiblement
n'est pas entendu par la majorité des
salariés qui ont besoin de cette
conférence salariale pour que tous les
employeurs de France à la mesure de leur
moyen de la taille de leurs entreprises
soutiennent leur pouvoir d'achat mais je
constate que vous êtes plus pro à
dégainer le 49-3 pour mettre fin à un
débat budgétaire pourtant absolument
riche comme l'a dit tout à l'heure
monsieur le ministre Véran qu'a organisé
ce que les salariés demandent de leurs
vœux depuis un petit moment maintenant
la parole est à notre collègue
anne-chalarcher pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adressait à
madame la Première ministre à vous
entendre madame tout va bien
alors que les Français le constatent
chaque jour la France devient le pays de
la pénurie pénurie de médicaments
pénurie de carburant pénurie des
transports confrontés à la grève
pénurie d'électricité annoncée pour cet
hiver et face à ces pénuries on fait le
terrible constat que le gouvernement n'a
rien anticipé
il aura fallu plusieurs semaines avant
de réquisitionner une partie du
personnel de quelques raffineries
résultat les Français font la queue
pendant des heures devant les rares
stations services ouvertes la grève
s'étend au centrale nucléaire on central
sur 18 était touchées hier cette grève
si elle se poursuit pourrait provoquer
une terrible pénurie d'électricité
RTE prévoit d'ailleurs je cite des
conséquences lourdes cet hiver si la
grève se poursuit
qu'attendez-vous pour protéger les
Français des pénuries dans ces secteurs
stratégiques vous faudra-t-il comme pour
les raffineries attendre plusieurs
semaines pour agir allez-vous enfin
réquisitionnez toutes les raffineries
allez vous réquisitionner le personnel
des centrales nucléaires allez-vous
mettre en place un service minimum dans
les transports comme le prévoit la
proposition de loi de Bruno retaillod
votez au Sénat la situation exige du
courage et des mesures fortes mais en
avez-vous
pour répondre la parole et communiste du
travail
plein emploi de l'insertion merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice pour avoir la chance de
partager avec madame la Première
ministre un certain nombre de rencontres
avec les différents présidents de groupe
dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites je peux vous assurer que les
partenaires sociaux qui ont à participer
pour je peux vous dire madame la
sénatrice que les partenaires sociaux
qui ont à participer au négociations
salariales dans les différents secteurs
ne se pose pas la question de savoir si
madame la Première ministre a de la
force et du courage il le constate il le
vivent et je peux témoigner des efforts
qu'elle met elle-même à à propulser et à
promouvoir ce dialogue je voudrais
revenir sur deux aspects de votre
question deux aspects de votre question
le premier concernant les centrales
nucléaires comme dans l'ensemble des
secteurs nous encourageons à la
négociation et aujourd'hui l'entreprise
doit ouvrir un cycle de négociation et
nous espérons que ce cycle de
négociation soit aussi nature à
dissuader cette grève à l'empêcher et à
permettre un bon fonctionnement vous
nous interrogez c'est le deuxième point
de votre question sur la question des
réquisitions je suis désolé de vous
rappeler madame la sénatrice que dans le
cadre du respect des droits
constitutionnels nous sommes évidemment
respectueux du droit de grève que la
jurisprudence en matière de réquisition
éclair que les réquisitions doivent être
proportionnées justifiées par un
impératif d'urgence ou de troubles à
l'ordre public et respectueuse de
l'exercice du droit syndical c'est ce
que nous avons fait en veillant à ce que
les réquisitions auxquelles nous avons
procédé pour ce qui concerne les
raffineries s'inscrivent parfaitement
dans ce cadre c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs
permis au tribunal administratif de
Lille et de Rouen de considérer que les
décisions prises par le gouvernement
étaient conformes à la loi et qu'elle
pouvait ainsi s'appliquer nous pouvons
nous affranchir des règles du droit et
parfois même des principes
constitutionnels sauf que cela n'existe
pas et que ça serait la meilleure façon
d'être dans l'inefficacité avec des
décisions qui seraient immédiatement
censurées par la justice administrative
[Applaudissements]
il faut agir
d'euro perdue pour l'économie française
qui viennent creuser encore plus la
dette abyssale la vérité c'est que votre
gouvernement est débordé débordé par ses
contradictions débordée par son
arrogance débordé par son déni de la
réalité par son incapacité à ressentir
une quelconque empathie vis-à-vis des
Français qui galèrent toujours et
toujours plus dans notre pays où règne
excusez-moi la chiant Lee
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue racheté mal pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
permettait moi ici d'être pour quelques
instants le porte-parole des régions des
départements des intercos des villes et
des villages notre pays c'est
collectivités qui encore une fois sont
très largement impactés par l'inflation
et qui voit leur coût multiplier par 8
à cette date rappelons quand même que
ces collectivités représentent 70% de
l'instant publique entre pays et donc
sans leur investissement ça dépend
entier notre économie qui s'effondrerait
et des emplois qui seraient détruits
rappelons qu'ici sur ces bancs nous
sommes tous à travailler au quotidien
avec les élus avec les associations
d'élus nous l'étions d'ailleurs
nous-même nous étions d'ailleurs dans le
Val-d'Oise ce weekend avec les collègues
ici présents et qu'est-ce qu'on constate
chez les élus locaux que nous
rencontrons d'abord pour la première
fois ils n'arrivent pas à boucler leur
budget c'est une première il nous disent
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui dans
l'obligation de s'interroger sur la
fermeture de services sur la suppression
de poste et on ne peut qu'imaginer les
Français qui dans quelques semaines
quelques mois iront dans leur piscine
dans leur gymnase et trouveront porte
close parce que il n'y aura pas pour les
collectiers les moyens d'ouvrir de les
financer alors Monsieur Miss ma question
est relativement simple
qu'entendez-vous modifier dans votre
projet de loi de finances 2023 sur les
collectivités pour qu'enfin ces
collectée puisse fonctionner dignement
et répondre au service public je
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole l'écho
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion du territoire monsieur
le président madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateurs
que vous avez croisé dans le Val-d'Oise
les membres du gouvernement les députés
les sénateurs des autres groupes les
rencontres aussi et personne ne peut
nier que ce retour de l'inflation à des
niveaux que nous n'avons pas connu même
si elle est plus faible en France
qu'ailleurs elle nette pas dans les
équations dont nous parlons à cela
s'ajoute la question de l'énergie et
puisque vous êtes fait le porte-parole
des départements des régions des villes
et des villages je veux quand même
rappeler que les villages de ce pays
sont protégés par le bouclier tarifaire
qui est le même que celui qui vaut pour
les ménages je vais donc me concentrer
sur les autres strates de collectivité
première chose
première chose si l'inflation pèse sur
les dépenses elle contribue parfois aux
recettes la progression des recettes de
TVA des régions c'est 9% pour l'année en
cours la revalorisation des bases
d'imposition c'est plus 1,2 milliards et
la revalorisation automatique ce sera
davantage l'année prochaine deuxième
chose des difficultés de bouclage pour
les budgets les collectivités locales en
ont connu quand des gouvernements que
vous soutient ont baissé de 11 milliards
la DGF il y a de cela quelques années
pour la première fois depuis 13 ans un
gouvernement celui qui est dirigé par
Elizabeth borne propose de revaloriser
le montant de la DGF de 200 puis 320
millions et ces chiffres seront
présentés dans quelques jours
quatrièmement un filet de sécurité
autrement plus robuste et plus solide
que celui que vous aviez contribué à
construire pendant le PLF sera inclus
dans le PLF qui vous sera transmis et ça
n'est que la deuxième étape de notre
grande bataille qui consiste d'abord à
obtenir une baisse des prix de l'énergie
c'est ce qui se joue demain et après
demain au Conseil européen et la
réflexion plus que la réflexion
l'établissement d'un dispositif de
protection tarifaire pour les
collectivités pour les entreprises qui
ne sont pas couvertes par le TRV à ce
stade 1 on se bat à l'échelle européenne
2 on utilise la contribution sur les
rentes pour solvabiliser des dispositifs
de compensation 3
on prévoit un filet de sécurité plus
plus pour compenser ce qui reste
[Applaudissements]
très bien monsieur le ministre je ne
suis pas certain que le maire Béchu
tiendrait les mêmes propos que vous
et je vous rassure j'ai bien indiqué
dans ma question que je parlais au
niveau de pour tous les banques je ne
parlais pas que de mes amis politiques
je parlais de tous les banques je crois
que tous les sénateurs c'est un ici
rencontre les mêmes difficultés quand
ils rencontrent les rencontres les mères
vous nous parlez des villages tant mieux
mais quand on rencontre les maires des
villages ils nous disent la même chose
et je vous rappelle que vos dispositifs
fait que 45 millions de Français ne sont
pas inclus dans vos mesures et donc ils
vont être eux pénalisés aussi donc la
question on peut toujours tourner en
rond mais aujourd'hui ce qu'on propose
simplement les associations d'élus c'est
qu'il y a un bouclier fiscal pour toutes
les communes pour toutes les communes et
qui n'a pas non plus leur capacité à
investir dans l'avenir ça vous pouvez au
moins l'accepter ou pas c'est ça la
vraie question qui nous est posée et
puis il y a aussi la question des bases
locatives etc parce que vous nous parlez
vous nous parlez de mesures mais je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle que vous
retirez la cree c'est 8 milliards de
moins pour aussi pour les collectivités
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Thierry
MEIGNAT pour le groupe les républicains
sur le président madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues monsieur le
ministre la réponse que vous avez
apportée à mon collègue temal ne nous
satisfait pas je voudrais vous rappeler
que comme vous le savez au 31 octobre
les contrats d'électricité de gaz se
termineront pour de nombreuses
collectivités territoriales et les
nouveaux contrats devront être signés au
1er novembre c'est-à-dire dans quelques
jours sous peine de coupure totale
ces régions ces départements ces villes
devront donc acheter l'électricité et le
gaz au prix du marché dans un contexte
dans un contexte de flambé débris de
l'énergie de nombreux élus locaux vous
ont d'ailleurs
alerté sur ce point chez nous en
Seine-Saint-Denis on nous annonce des
prix tout à fait insupportables une
multiplication par 15 des prix du gaz 32
du prix d'électricité en
Seine-Saint-Denis comme partout en
France une commune moyenne passerait
donc de 2 à 15 millions d'euros en
termes de dépenses d'énergie
comme vous en avez pris l'habitude
lorsqu'il s'agit des collectivités
territoriales et des élus locaux votre
réponse n'est pas à la hauteur monsieur
le ministre le ministre des comptes
publics a proposé une aide 438 millions
d'euros largement insuffisante s'il
avait s'il avait ouvertement souhaité
afficher son mépris pour les mères il ne
s'y serait pas pris autrement
surtout cette aide de s'appliquera qu'au
commune dont l'épargne brute c'est
fortement dégradé ces dernières années
comme d'habitude vous avez choisi de
sanctionner d'abord les bons élèves les
communes qui gèrent correctement
l'argent de leurs administrés
monsieur le ministre vous demandez
beaucoup d'efforts aux collectivités aux
entreprises aux Français vous avez
demandé aux salariés de porter des cols
rouler dans les bureaux vous avez
demandé aux écoliers de grelotter dans
les salles de classe les Français ont
consenti beaucoup d'efforts ils ont
constitueront ils ont consciront encore
mais ils ne doivent pas être les seuls à
consentir ces efforts monsieur le
ministre que répondez-vous aux nombreux
maires qui ne savent pas aujourd'hui
comment ils feront face à la flambée des
prix de l'énergie doivent-ils sacrifier
les services à la population pour payer
leurs factures de gaz et d'électricité
pour vous répondre la parole au ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous avez utilisé un mot que
je n'aurais pas choisi
c'est le mot de mépris il y a plusieurs
manières de mépriser les gens et une de
celle-là c'est d'être dans l'outrance
dans la caricature et de faire en sorte
de présenter les choses d'une manière
qui soit totalement dévié
on peut avoir un débat il peut être
respectueux et il peut surtout reposer
sur des réalités la réalité c'est que
pour la première fois depuis 13 ans il y
a une augmentation de la DGF la DGF elle
a pas été désindexée par l'actuel
gouvernement elle a été par la majorité
de la du Sénat qui se trouvait de ce
côté-ci et elle a été baissée ensuite
par celle-là donc à un moment revenir à
la réalité c'est une nécessité sur les
tarifs sur les tarifs la preuve a
présenté ce que sont les tarifs cibles
une dimultiplication par 15 ou par 30
c'est en dehors de ce qui se pratique
partout et là le conseil c'est de ne pas
signer sur des niveaux qui sont
délirants d'opérateurs qui profitent de
la situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons
faites aussi votre part en termes je ne
peux pas croire que vous fassiez votre
temps dans vos départements à relayer
des fausses informations ou alimenter
une inquiétude au lieu d'insister sur
les dispositifs exister le rendez-vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est simple
c'est les choses sont assez simples
se faire applaudir au Sénat en disant
qu'on ne donne pas assez pour les
collectivités locales qui sont bien
gérées par rapport à l'État qui les mal
ça garantit le succès à tous les coups
la réalité c'est la responsabilité la
responsabilité par rapport au finances
publiques que vous ne cessez d’invoquer
la responsabilité par rapport à un
dispositif qui tienne la route sur le
plan européen et de ce point de vue
Henri Jésus est ce qui vous sera proposé
et regardez à la fois la robustesse du
filet nouveau qui a été conçu et la
réalité des hausses de DGF et là on aura
un débat sur le fond et pas sur des
postures
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Patrick
Chauvet pour le groupe Union centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des Transports la
voiture électrique et sans conteste la
star du Mondial de l'auto et pour cause
puisque la vente des véhicules
thermiques sera interdite à partir de
2035 si cet objectif se justifie sur le
plan environnemental il fait peser un
risque majeur sur l'industrie automobile
française en l'état actuel des choses
généraliser la voiture électrique s'est
déroulé le tapis rouge à la Chine les
grands constructeurs européens ont
consenti des investissements colossaux
pour améliorer les performances
écologiques des moteurs thermiques avec
le tout électrique ces efforts sont
passés par pertes et profits nous sommes
en train d'offrir une industrie
d'excellence à l'Asie aujourd'hui la
moitié de la chaîne de valeur du
véhicule électrique est encore situé en
Asie la Chine contrôle 56% de la
production mondial de batterie des
batteries dont nous devons importer les
principaux composants quand nous les
fabriquons ici résultat nous ne sommes
pas compétitifs les voitures électriques
chinoises coûtent 20 à 30% moins cher
que les européennes les constructeurs
estiment qu'il leur faudra entre 5 et 7
ans pour résorber cet écart 19% des
voitures électriques vendues en Europe
sont d'ores et déjà fabriquées en Chine
et ce ne sont pas les dispositifs d'aide
à l'acquisition d'une voiture électrique
qui vont les aider la location avec
option d'achat ne sera pas possible
avant 2024 c'est bien pour cela que vous
venez d'augmenter la prime à l'achat qui
va passer de 6 à 7000 euros pour les
ménages les plus modestes ce faisant
nous allons massivement subventionné les
constructeurs chinois les États-Unis
viennent de réserver leurs incitations
fiscales au seul véhicules électriques
dotés de batterie produite en Amérique
ne peut-on pas aussi cibler nos aides
sur les constructeurs européens je vous
remercie
vous répondre la parole est au ministre
délégué en charge des transports
monsieur bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Chauvet vous avez raison
d'abord de souligner l'importance de ce
Mondial de l'Auto le premier depuis 4
ans et de souligner ce qui est sans
doute n'aurait pas été imaginable il y a
encore quelques années comme la rappelle
le ministre Lescure qu'il est
entièrement consacré pardon aux
véhicules décarbonés en particulier aux
véhicules électriques vous avez raison
aussi d’alerter sur les risques sur les
risques d'atteinte à notre souveraineté
et de protection nécessaire notre
filière automobile face à cerise vous
avez deux réponses possibles soit nous
considérons que le choix de la
décarbonation de la transition
écologique pourrait être remise en cause
soit nous considérons dans cette
hypothèse que nous ne pourrions nous
pourrions faire l'économie de
l'investissement dans le véhicule
électrique massivement et rapidement
je crois que renoncer à des carbonation
renoncer la transition écologique
renoncée à l'électrification personne ne
le propose nous devons alors assumer
cette transition nous devons l'affronter
et sans être naïf ni excessivement
optimiste nous avons démontré ces
dernières années que affronter cette
transition et ne pas la refuser pour se
réfugier si je puis dire dans le confort
du thermique ou du statu quo qui
d'ailleurs a montré que la baisse de
production était déjà là avant la
question de l'électrification nous avons
engagé une réindustrialisation et il y a
5 ans nous n'aurions pas pensé que la
France aurait pu vous avez souligner ce
point produire commencer à produire des
batteries et retrouver progressivement
et rapidement son indépendance car le
président de la République a fixé ce cap
et aujourd'hui crédible nous pouvons sur
les batteries atteindre l'indépendance
de production d'ici 2027 et donc la
transition électrique nous devons
l'amener en réindustrialisant en
investissant en soutenant l'achat de
véhicules électriques en incitant notre
filière nos constructeurs et l'ensemble
de l'écosystème à produire électrique en
France et en Europe on ne peut pas
renoncer à cet objectif on peut en
revanche
monter en construisant une filière et
c'est possible votre département de la
Seine-Maritime le connaît avec les
transformations en cours des sites de
Renault en particulier à Cléon et à
Dieppe ce qui paraissait improbable il y
a quelques années est en cours et donc
se relever ce défi de
l'industrialisation électrique en Europe
nous pouvons le faire cela nécessitera
en effet réformer nos outils de
concurrence réformer nos outils de
protection commerciale aller vers la
Russie prostituée et faire en sorte vous
l'avez dit que les aides que nous devons
au consommateurs et aux constructeurs ne
soient pas ciblés vers ceux qui de Chine
essayent de gagner notre marché
aujourd'hui
merci quelques secondes monsieur Chauvet
merci monsieur le Président oui toute la
réponse était pas à la question
ceci étant vous avez évoqué le droit
européen je crois que ça mérite de s'y
pencher parce que je voudrais simplement
rappeler que au-delà des discours les
conséquences par ricochet sur l'emploi
dans cette filière automobile seront
terribles merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Vincent Segoin pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre crise énergétique
difficulté d'approvisionnement et de
recrutement l'industrie est de plus en
plus affectée la situation des
trésorerie continue de se dégrader dans
tous les secteurs et très en deçà de la
moyenne de long terme conclusion du
rapport de la Banque de France sur la
conjoncture en octobre 2022 assez
difficultés se rajoutent le
remboursement du PGE et des charges
sociales qui n'ont pas été réclamés
depuis 2021 forcément ces charges
exceptionnelles sont trop lourdes pour
les entreprises et les rendre
vulnérables à ce sujet ici en commission
des finances nous vous avions déjà
alerté sur la durée de remboursement des
PGE que l'on jugeait incompatible avec
la marge des entreprises alors vous
allez me répondre que les entreprises
peuvent revoir la durée du remboursement
du PGE à condition de passer par la
médiation du crédit oui mais médiation
est une entité adossée à la Banque de
France si la réponse est négative
l'entreprise devra rentrer dans une
procédure collective si elle est
positive l'emprunt sera apparenté à
restructuration de la dette et donc
considérer comme des empreintes non
performants sur le bilan cela aura donc
un impact sur la cotation d'entreprise
et quel qu'en soit la taille bilan
l'entreprise ne pourra plus souscrire
aux emprunts bancaires pour innover
aussi développer vous comprenez alors
pourquoi cette option est si peu utilisé
et pourquoi bon nombre de chefs
d'entreprise rendent leur patrimoine
personnel au risque de tout perdre
l'entreprise France a une moyenne de 6
salariés toutes tailles confondues y
compris le CAC 40 vous avez entrepris
une démarche de réindustrialisation de
la France mais ne laissons pas tomber si
TPE et PME qui se découragent face à
cette situation pensez-vous ré-étaler le
PGE sans médiation particulière et à
surseoir temporairement le remboursement
des cotisations sociales des années
antérieures
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunication
monsieur Barrault
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénateur monsieur le
sénateur merci pour votre question qui
est l'occasion de rappeler à quel point
les prêts garantis par l'État les PGE
ont permis au début de la crise de la
covid de sauver notre tissu
entrepreneurial avec 140 milliards de
près consentis dans votre département de
l'Orne ce sont plus de 260 millions
d'euros qui ont été prêtés à plus de
1700 entreprises désormais vous avez
raison de le rappeler se pose la
question du remboursement il n'y a pas
de risque systémique identifié à ce
stade sur sur ces sur ces prêts
garanties par l'État puisque le taux
prévisionnel de défaut sur ces prêts est
estimé aujourd'hui à 5%. mais évidemment
nous sommes conscients qu'un certain
nombre d'entreprises dans la conjoncture
actuelle rencontrent des difficultés
pour les remboursements de ces prêts et
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
dispositif qui a évolué tout au long de
la crise a fait l'objet d'une de
décision pour ouvrir des facultés
d'amortissement
qui ont été prises en juillet 2021 et en
février 2022 et en particulier pour les
entreprises qui avaient pris un prêt de
moins de 50000 euros elles peuvent se
tourner vers le médiateur du crédit vous
l'avez dit placé auprès de la Banque de
France pour celle qui ont souscrit un
prêt de plus de 50 000 euros elles
peuvent se tourner vers le conseiller
départemental de sortie de crise qui va
les orienter soit vers une solution de
restructuration de leur dette qu'elle
soit PGE ou qu'elle soit une dette des
Urssaf soit vers une procédure
préventive de conciliation vous avez
alerté sur la question de la notation
effectivement certaines entreprises sont
inquiète de voir leur note dégradée il
faut rappeler que pour les entreprises
qui font moins de 750 000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires celle-ci ne dispose
pas d'une notation FIBEN il n'y a donc
pas lieu qu'elle soit dégradée et seule
la banque en question sera au courant de
la restructuration pour celles qui font
plus de 750 000 euros il faut rappeler
que la dégradation de la note n'est pas
systématique qu'elle fait l'objet d'une
analyse au cas par cas par la Banque de
France et que la discussion est ouverte
et je rappelle en conclusion
que ces facultés viennent en complément
des décisions qui ont été prises par la
première ministre pour venir en aide de
manière conjoncturelle à nos TPE et PME
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
je vous remercie
monsieur
[Musique]
ministre déjà je suis surpris par
rapport à vos compétences que vous
répondiez à ma question première chose
la seconde vous tenez pas vous tenez
compte du taux de contentieux sans tenir
compte de la radiation des entreprises
qui est 37% supplémentaires à celui du
taux de 2019 les entreprises abandonnent
aujourd'hui on vous avait prévenu sur le
PGE que la durée de remboursement elle
serait trop courte vous faites vous le
c'est simple votre réponse c'est
circuler il n'y a rien à voir et bien je
suis désolé vous étiez fier de défendre
les entreprises mais là vous les mettez
dans le décor et sans suivre navré
merci la parole de notre collègue Angel
prévu pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
fort une condamnation pour inaction
avant-hier le Conseil d'État a condamné
l'État à une astreinte de 20 millions
d'euros pour non-respect des seuils de
pollution de l'air en dioxyde d'azote
dans les grandes agglomérations Paris
Lyon Marseille sur la période du 1er
juillet 2021 au 1er juillet 2022 22
l'État avait déjà été condamné il y a un
an pour les mêmes raisons à 10 millions
d'euros cela sanctionne l'insuffisance
des mesures et moyens mise en oeuvre
pour ramener les émissions de ce gaz
sous le seuil de 40 microgrammes par
mètre cube principale émetteur les
moteurs thermiques soit le trafic
routier ce gaz le dioxyde d'azote se
dissout dans l'eau pour donner de
l'acide nitrique c'est d'ailleurs un
procédé de fabrication de la symétrique
produit corrosif par excellence très
concrètement si vous le respirez
mesdames et messieurs les ministres et
mes chers collègues dans votre nez dans
vos poumons qui sont humides le dioxyde
d'azote va ainsi dissoudre dans cette
humidité c'est de l'acidité qui va se
former sur les parois de votre nez et
dans vos poumons c'est pourquoi vous
allez ressentir des picotements et des
irritations et si vous y êtes exposé
régulièrement des inflammations avec
pour conséquence des quantités de
pathologiques crises maladie pulmonaire
cancer du poumon les plus vulnérables
les enfants donc elle est plus pauvres
sont les plus touchés bilan annuels 40
000 décès prématurés dans la nature
c'est le même phénomène de formation
d'assignétrique au contact de l'eau qui
provoque plus acide acidification des
océans eurofisations des eaux douces et
qui constitue un facteur majeur de
baisse de la biodiversité or le trafic
routier par camion n'a pas baissé il
s'intensifie le fratéroviaire n'est
toujours pas revenu au niveau des années
80 soit 30% du transport de marchandises
et les mobilités douces ne sont toujours
pas suffisamment encouragés monsieur le
ministre pensez-vous que nous soyons sur
la bonne voie
vous répondre la parole est au ministre
de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice nous avons
évidemment priacte du maintien par le
Conseil d'État de ces astreintes pour
les deux semestres depuis la
condamnation d'août 2021 je ne doute pas
compte tenu du degré de précision dans
lequel vous êtes entré que vous avez lu
cette avis du Conseil d'État qui pointe
le fait qu'il y a un maintien de
dépassement de seuil mais une
amélioration de la situation en 2017
nous avions 13 agglomérations qui
étaient en déplacement de seuil ce
chiffre est passé à 8 en 2020 à 5 en
2021 et il est de 3 Paris Lyon et
Aix-Marseille à la minute où nous
parlons mais le sujet c'est pas le
nombre d'agglo c'est bien d'abord le
nombre de décès plus de 40000 plus de
40000 décès liés à la pollution de l'air
et notre engagement il est de faire en
sorte de diminuer ses décès la ligne du
gouvernement c'est la protection des
Français et cette protection elle vaut
d'abord sur les sujets environnementaux
extrêmement concrètes ce que le Conseil
d'État nous appelle c'est à amplifier à
renforcer ou à rendre plus efficiente
les zones affaiblissement
mardi prochain je recevrai au ministère
avec les membres les présidents des
intercommunalités des métropoles les
maires de toutes les villes de plus de
150 000 habitants pour faire un point
sur là où nous en sommes une dizaine
d'agglomérations ils sont déjà passés
d'autre part certaines rencontres des
difficultés d'autres
anticipent des difficultés on a de vrais
sujets d'accessibilité sociale parce que
les aid effet ne doivent pas être des
moyens d'empêcher les plus fragiles
d'entrer dans les villes il y a donc la
question des compensations il y a la
question des moyens il y a la question
de l'information il y a des dispositifs
innovants avec Strasbourg qui teste un
passe avec d'autres qui majorent des
aides ou des primes à la conversion tous
ces sujets seront sur la table avec un
objectif protéger les Français améliorer
la qualité de l'air tout
particulièrement dans le domaine du
dioxyde d'azote et des particules fines
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Valérie Boyer pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
de la justice et de la liberté en
particulier ceux du groupe France
Arménie le 13 septembre l'Azerbaïdjan a
lancé une nouvelle offensive contre
l'Arménie malgré l'indifférence presque
générale c'est bien une nouvelle guerre
de conquête et d'extermination qui se
joue aux portes de l'Europe avec son
premier lot de crime de guerre fièrement
exhibé sur la toile par les militaires
azerbaïdjanais ce filmant dans leurs
œuvres de viol de torture de
démembrement cette logique génocidaire
cette arménophobie ce racisme d'État
pratiqué par l'Azerbaïdjan avec le
soutien de la Turquie n'a pas vocation à
s'arrêter à ce pays il y a Malia a
d'ailleurs déclaré vouloir chassé ses
chiens d'Arménien alors madame la
ministre que comptez-vous faire
concrètement pour éviter que cette part
de l'histoire de l'humanité que ce pays
souverain la République d'Arménie ne
disparaisse
pour la parole avec la madame la
ministre de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères madame Colonna monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Boyer je
vous remercie de votre question qui me
permet qui me permet de revenir sur
quelques points évoquer récemment ici
même la France vous le savez est
pleinement solidaire de l'armée ni face
aux violations de sa souveraineté pour
stabiliser la situation pour que
l'Arménie recouvre son intégrité
territoriale et pour accompagner la
reprise des négociations cette
mobilisation porte ses fruits outre la
relance de la dynamique au Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies sous
présidence française les ministres des
Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne ont décidé lundi le lancement
rapide d'une mission européenne
d'observation qui se déplorera le long
de la frontière arménienne et cela a été
rendu possible par l'accord trouvé entre
les deux pays sous l'égide du président
de la République le 6 octobre au plus
exactement dans la nuit du 6 7 octobre
car il a passé un certain temps comme le
souhaitait l'Arménie par ailleurs nous
avons aussi pu faire accepter une
mission d'évaluation de l'OSCE qui sera
sur place dès vendredi et permettra de
faire un constat de la situation et des
besoins notamment des besoins
humanitaires et visera la relance du
processus de négociation et de
délimitation de la frontière je vous
avais parlé de ces trois sujets et ils
ont avancé tout trois aucune de ces
avancées n'aurait été possible sans
l'engagement de la France jusqu'au plus
haut niveau de l'État madame la
sénatrice donc vous le voyez l'Arménie
peut compter sur la France et l'œuvre
pour la paix et pour la stabilité dans
le Caucase dans l'intérêt de tous je
vous remercie
madame Boyer comment y croire Madame la
Ministre comment croire une Europe qui
d'un côté va envoyer cette mission
civile sur place mais qui de l'autre
renforce la coopération avec
l'Azerbaïdjan notamment en matière
énergétique avec une Ursula avant
derléen qui va en aller à faire un
partenaire fiable sur lequel on peut
compter Bruxelles est prête à sacrifier
la vie des Arméniens sur le tel de ses
intérêts énergétiques qu'en est-il
vraiment de la France la vie des
arts-médiens vaut-elle vaut-elle moins
que celle des Ukrainiens cette
tartufferie européenne va plus loin
puisque le gaz vendu par l'Azerbaïdjan
proviendrait d'une exploitation en
partie détenue par une société russe
l'Arménie est une part de nous-mêmes une
part de notre civilisation de notre
culture de nos croyances nous avons même
une journée nationale pour commémorer le
génocide de 1915 les Arméniens de
demande qu'une chose le droit de vivre
le droit de disposer d'eux-mêmes ce qui
est valable pour la Russie devrait
l'être pour l'autocratie azeri il y a
d'ailleurs une entente entre ces deux
pays Poutine veut prendre la géographie
à l'if veut annuler l'histoire le
premier conquiert le second efface dit
justement Sylvain Tesson ce grand témoin
demandant des sanctions contre
l'Azerbaïdjan et appliquons les madame
gelons les ovoirs du clan à l'if sans
avoir la main qui tremble ou qui triche
opposons-nous à la diplomatie de la
menace à la caviar connection envisage
envisageant un soutien militaire pour
l'Arménie des armes pour l'Arménie ce
que nous avons fait pour le Mali
pourquoi ne pas le faire pour l'Arménie
et dénonçons cet accord inique sur le
gaz car refusé ses sanctions cautionner
l'épuration ethnique des Arméniens une
nouvelle phase du génocide peut-être la
solution finale pour eux malheureusement
c'est clamer au monde que les valeurs
dont nous ne réclamons ne sont que des
supercheries alors agissons concrètement
et la parole est à notre collègue lors
d'Archos pour le groupe les républicains
et de la jeunesse monsieur le ministre
la République a toujours besoin de
savants elle doit donc commencer par
favoriser les pépinières scientifiques
la réforme du lycée a été bâclée avec
comme seul objectif une économie de
moyens deux ans plus tard le bilan que
nous pouvons adresser est bien
inquiétant oui l'heure est grave
monsieur le ministre c'est toute une
filière qui est en train de couler nous
ne formons plus assez de scientifiques
alors même que la France a fait le choix
de réinvestir massivement dans la
recherche publique et l'innovation en
deux ans entre 2019 et 2021 le nombre
d'élèves scientifiques en terminale a
diminué de 24%. les élèves bénéficiant
d'un enseignement renforcé en
mathématiques sont de moins en moins
nombreux la part des jeunes filles dans
l'ensemble des parcours scientifiques
est aussi en chute libre 20 ans
d'efforts pour les amener à s'engager
dans des formations exigeantes autrefois
largement réservée aux garçons ont été
balayés d'un trait de plumes
les mathématiques la physique la chimie
le numérique les sciences informatiques
les sciences de l'ingénieur ont tout
disparu du tronc commun et sont
aujourd'hui relégués au rendant de
spécialités ou d'enseignement optionnel
en Première et en terminale les mesures
annoncées à la hâte à la fin de l'année
scolaire 2021-2022 ne sont qu'un écran
de fumée vous ne pouvez pas décemment
former un ingénieur en lui enseignant
1h30 de mathématiques dans le tronc
commun en première et trois heures
d'option mathématiques complémentaires
pour tous en terminale c'est toute la
structure du style terminal qu'il faut
revoir sans délai si nous voulons
répondre à l'exigence scientifique des
formations du supérieur et produire les
compétences dont dépend notre et nous
économie ma question est simple monsieur
le ministre elle dictée par l'urgence
allez-vous suspendre cette réforme et
réunir toutes les parties prenantes afin
de réfléchir à la mise en oeuvre de
solutions efficaces et durables pour
renverser ce déclin dès la rentrée 2023
à défaut je crois que notre compatriote
Hugo du minil copain qui a reçu en
juillet dernier la médaille Fields pour
ses travaux en physique statistique et
le travail à Bures-sur-Yvette dans mon
département soit le dernier Français à
recevoir cette prestigieuse récompense
je vous remercie de votre réponse
[Applaudissements]
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'heure d'Argos je vous
remercie de cette question qui m'offre
l'occasion de souligner deux points le
premier commence par un paradoxe l'école
française de mathématiques compte parmi
les meilleurs du monde c'est un sujet de
fierté pour notre pays 13 médailles-fils
des prix Nobel scientifiques y compris
cette année et d'un autre côté un niveau
moyen en mathématiques médiocre dans la
population générale et aussi dans la
population scolaire française on le voit
aux évaluations nationales mais aussi au
classement internationaux ou la place de
la France en mathématiques du côté des
populations scolaires n'est pas
reluisante face à cela nous avons
d'abord de façon rapide
réintroduit une heure et demie de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun pour
les élèves de première cela obéissait
une demande d'insistante des sociétés de
mathématiques et nous l'avons fait nous
allons poursuivre cet effort l'année
prochaine mais je le reconnais cela ne
suffit pas il faut avoir un regard
global sur l'enseignement des
mathématiques qui ne dépend pas du
volume d'heures mathématiques car la
France se situe plutôt dans le haut du
panier en la matière en revanche quand
on regarde les résultats on voit que ça
n'a cela ne correspond pas évidemment à
ce volume d'heures et donc on a bien un
sujet qui est le sujet de la pédagogie
de l'enseignement des mathématiques
comme le rapport torosian Villani là
soulevé de façon très claire le deuxième
point que vous soulevez c'est la place
en baisse des filles dans les dans les
enseignements une -28% entre 2019 et
2021 c'est pourquoi je vous annonce pour
réfléchir et prendre des mesures fortes
en la matière je sais que la première
ministre est très motivée par cette
question
la tenue d'assise nationale sur la place
des femmes dans l'enseignement et dans
le monde scientifique cet automne avec
mes collègues ministres de
l'enseignement supérieur et de l'égalité
femme homme pour prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent je vous l'accorde c'est
désormais une priorité pour nous nous
devons en tenir compte dans les
retouches que nous allons faire de la
réforme du lycée merci
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité les prochaines auront lieu
mercredi 26 octobre je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen d'approvision de loi
constitutionnelle visant à protéger la
garantir le droit fondamental à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception la séance est
suspendue